if we could talk about maybe
experimental validation and you you're
the co-author of a recently published
book proving Einstein right the the
human story of it to the daring
expeditions that changed how we look at
the universe DC echoes of the early days
of general relativity in the 1910s to
the more stretched out to string theory
I just nodded I do and that's one reason
why I was happy to focus on on the story
of how Einstein became a global
superstar earlier in our discussion we
went over the the his history where in
1915 he he came up this piece of
mathematics used it to do some
calculations and then made a prediction
yes but making a prediction is not
enough someone's got to go out and
measure and so string theory is in that
in-between zone now for Einstein it was
from 1915 to 1919 1950 he makes the
makes the correct prediction by the way
he made an incorrect prediction about
the same thing in 1911 but he corrected
himself in 1915 and by 1919 the first
pieces of experimental observational
data became available to say yes he's
not wrong and by 1922 the the argument
that based on observation was
overwhelming that he was not wrong he
described what special and general
relativity are just briefly sure since
and what prediction Einstein made and
maybe maybe some or memorable moment
from the human journey of trying to
prove this thing right she was
incredible right so I'm very fortunate
to have worked with a talented novelist
who wanted to write a book that
coincided with a book I wanted to write
about how sighs kind of feels if you're
a person
because it's actually people who do
science even though that may not be
obvious to everyone so for me I wanted
to write this book for a couple of
reasons I wanted young people to
understand that the seeming alien Giants
that live before them weren't just as
human as they are you get married you
get divorced again marry they're getting
worse they do terrible things they do
great things they're people they're just
people like you and so that part of
telling the story allowed me to get that
out there for both young people interest
in the sciences as well as the public
but the other part of the story is I
wanted to open up sort of what what it
was like now I'm a scientist and so I
will not pretend to be a great writer I
understand a lot about mathematics and
I've even created my own mathematics
that you know it's kind of a weird thing
to be able to do but in order to tell
the story you really have to have an
incredible master of the narrative and
my that was my co-author Kathy Pelletier
who is in office we so we formed this
conjoined brain I used to call us she's
the call us professor Higgins and there
lies that Doolittle my expression for us
is that we were conjoined brain to tell
this story and it allowed so what are
some magical moments to me the first
magical moment in telling the story was
looking at Albert Einstein in his
struggle because although we regard him
as a genius
as I said in 1911 he actually made an
incorrect prediction about spinning
starlight and that's actually what set
the astronomers off in 1914 there was an
eclipse and by various accidents of war
and weather and all sorts of things that
we talked about in the book no one was
able to make the measurement if they had
made the measurement it would have
disagreed with his 1911 prediction
because nature only has one answer and
so you then you see how fortunate
he was that Wars and bad weather and
accidents and transporting equipment
stopped any measurements from being made
so he corrects himself in 1915 and but
the astronomers are already out there
trying to make the measurement so now he
gives them a different number and it
turns out that's the number that nature
agrees with so it gives you a sense of
this is a person struggling with
something deeply and it although his
deep insight led him to this it is the
circumstance of time place an accident
but through which we view him and it
could the story could have turned out
very differently where first he makes a
prediction the measurements are made in
1914 they disagree with his prediction
and so what would the world view him as
well he's this professor who made this
prediction that didn't get it right yes
so the fragility of human history is
illustrated by that story and it's one
of my favorite things he also learned
things like in our book how eclipses and
watching eclipses was a driver of the
development of science in our nation
when it was very young in fact even
before we were a nation turns out there
were citizens or citizens of this
would-be country that were going out
trying to measure eclipses so some
fortune some misfortune affects the
progress of science especially with
ideas as to me at least if I put myself
back in those days as radicals general
relativity is first can you describe if
it's okay briefly what general
relativity is and yeah if you could you
just take a moment of yeah put yourself
in those shoes in the eka and academic
researchers scientists of that time and
what is this theory what is it trying to
describe about our world it's trying to
answer the thing that left Isaac Newton
puzzled
Isaac Newton says gravity magically goes
from one place to another he doesn't
believe it by the way he knows that's
not right but the mathematics is so good
that you have to say well I'll throw my
qualms away because I'll use it that's
all we use to get for a man from the
earth to the moon was that mathematics
so I'm one of those scientists and I've
seen this and if I thought deeply about
it maybe I know that Newton himself
wasn't comfortable and so the first
thing I would hope that I would feel is
gee there's this young kid out there who
has an idea to fill in this hole that
was laid left with us by Sir Isaac
Newton that would I hope would be my
reaction I have a suspicion I'm I'm kind
of a mathematical creature I was four
years old when I first decided that size
was what I wanted to do with my life and
so if my personality back then was like
it is now I think it's probably likely I
would want to want to have studied his
mathematics what was a piece of
mathematics that he was using to make
this prediction because he didn't
actually create that mathematics that
mathematics was created of roughly 50
years before he lived he's the person
who harnessed it in order to make a
prediction in fact he had to be taught
this mathematics by a friend so this is
in our book so putting myself in that
time I would want to like say I think I
have a felix it-- meant I would want to
know what the mathematics is and then I
would want to do the calculations myself
because one thing that physics is all
about is that you don't have to take
anybody's word for anything it's you can
do it yourself it does seem that
mathematics is a little bit more
tolerant of radical ideas or
mathematicians or people who find beauty
in mathematics why all the white
questions have no good answer let me ask
why do you think Einstein never got the
Nobel Prize for general relativity he
got it for the photoelectric effect that
is correct
well there first of all that's something
that is misunderstood about the Nobel
Prize in Physics the Nobel Prize in
Physics is never given for purely giving
for purely proposing an idea it is
always given for proposing an idea that
has observational support so he could
not get the Nobel Prize for either
special relativity nor generality
because the provisions that Alfred Nobel
left for the award prevent that but
after it's been validated cannot get it
then or no yes but remember the
validation doesn't really come until the
1920s but that's why they invented the
second Nobel Prize I mean very Creed you
can get in second Nobel Prize for one of
the greatest so so Larry's in physics so
let me let's be clear on this the theory
of general relativity had its critics
even up until the 50s so if you had if
we had if the committee had wanted to
give the prize for general relativity
there were vociferous critics of general
relativity up until the 50s Einstein
died in 1955 what lessons do you draw
from from the story tell in the book
from general activity from the radical
nature of the theory to looking at the
future string theory well I think that
the string theorists are probably going
to retrace this path but it's gonna be
far longer and more torturous in my
opinion string theory is such a broad
and deep development that in my opinion
when it becomes acceptable it's going to
be because of a confluence of
observation it's not going to be a
single observation and I have to tell
you that so I give a seminar here
yesterday to my team and it's it's on an
idea I have about how string theory can
leave signatures in the Cosmic Microwave
Background which is a Astro physical
structure and so if those kinds of
observations are borne out if perhaps
other things related to
the idea of supersymmetry worn out those
are gonna be the first powerful
observational II based pieces of
evidence that we'll begin to do what the
Eddington expedition did in 1919 but who
that may take several decades do you
think there will be Nobel Prizes given
for string theory no because I think the
arrays
it'll be you'll be I think it will
exceed normal human lifetimes then but
there are other prizes that are given I
mean there is something called the
breakthrough prize there's a Russian
emigre a Russian American immigrant
named Yuri Milner I believe his name
started this wonderful prize called the
breakthrough prize it's three times as
much money since Nobel Prize and he gets
awarded every year and so something like
one of those prizes is likely to be
garnered at some point far earlier than
a Nobel award
you